talked to me about 2024 would you like  to when might he decide whether he's  going to run or not  you know nobody can speak for him have  you spoken to him about it uh he's asked  me about it I said You Know It's Tricky  what did he ask you uh I'd rather not go  into that but but basically I know that  he's um he's obviously thinking about it  he hates seeing what's happening in the  country you know he had the economy  running so well he filled the whole  economically that was caused by covid he  got us out of it with the vaccine but um  when will he decide when will he have to  decide we're heading towards the  midterms aren't we so he's going to have  to decide soon uh when he's ready not  really though is he I'm sorry he's not  ruling it out like I said with Trump  it's hard to rule anything out so he's  uh he's a very flexible thing